padre starter is the right-hander
garrett richards has fought through all
kinds of injury problems the last few
years to have a comeback kind of season
this year yastremski will stand in it is
four o'clock it is baseball time again
in the air to left field pro far on the
move back towards the corner pro far
still going and he makes the catch into
the slide in the left field corner
spectacular running diving catch for
jericho profile
alex dickerson homeboy for a double
header
was in the lineup of course for game one
on thursday before the postponement
friday saturday
there's a pop-up off of third base
machado going as far as she can over by
the seats and machado makes the catch
manny machado against the screening and
the short fencing nicely done and foul
ground to make the grab
so that'll bring up longoria
here's the 2-2
swing at a bit strike three
slider
and it was a real good one clevenger
they they had a diet of sliders in the
first game they're gonna see sliders in
their sleep tonight san francisco and
that one was fantastic a strikeout
longoria the two walks do no damage here
for the padres and the veteran garrett
richards the giants leave a pair giants
starting pitcher logan webb
coming off arguably his worst start of
the year against
the seattle mariners two down machado at
first base and brings up mitch moreland
here it is another change up and he
struck him out swinging
[Applause]
so webb
getting the change up and using it to
good effect
we head to the second inning
smoke coming up then crawford
it is nothing to nothing here in game
two the padres won game one six another
so two down and here is yasremski
[Applause]
shoots this one down the right field
line that's a fair ball
crawford's gonna score
what's bart gonna do bart's gonna put on
the brakes at third and the giants are
on the board it is a double for mike
yostremski and the giants have their
first run of the day
here in game two of the doubleheader one
to nothing giants
so now one run is in and here is alex
dickerson to see if he can drive in some
more two runners in scoring position
on one ground ball picked nicely by
moreland underhand feed at first base
that is that hey cheaply enough
cheaply enough alex dickerson the very
slow guy able to get in there first base
pitcher covering the garrett richards
3-1 in your scoreboard but one run
on a couple of hits and a man left for
the giants one out second inning and
here's will myers
[Applause]
will myers high fly ball to deep center
field way on back there at the wall
leaping up can't get it a long gone will
myers having himself a 20 20.
what a season
dead central straight out there in
center field
this game just like that
1-1 short live lead san francisco giants
eh
here's longoria who struck out in the
first one-to-one the score
pitch 50 is lying to short and caught on
the year by tatis on the backhand and a
1-2-3 third for garrett richards two
down pro far man second base and here's
manny machado
machado waiting one-two pitch is swung
on and missed strike three got it with a
slider
so logan webb some good pitching there
after a mistake to start the inning he
got through the big boys after the lead
off walk two on nobody out and jerks and
pro far coming up
323 with runners in scoring position you
bought him right here
i would i would too
i really would get it down at the top of
the order coming up
giants think he is he is squaring but
pulls it back swings away and grounds
one past longorian to left field now
chronoworth coming around the throw will
be
late and the padres take it to one lead
showed bunt pulled it back slashed away
and drives it into left field and drives
in a run and puts a padres on top two to
one
fernando has grounded into a field of
choice and struck out looking here's
roger's set the right-hander dips down
throws slider ground to the third
longoria's got it wheels around throws
home the tag and he's out
first in third
two down and manny machado no balls and
his strike and tatis has hardly any lead
at all not running and mandy suits this
one into right field for a base hit
profar will come in and score rbi single
manny machado and the padre is up three
to one as the throw comes in behind
fernando and crawford tags him out to
end the inning padres will get the run
but tatis took a little bit of an
aggressive turn at second base and the
giant's able to get him to end the fifth
however a couple of runs on a couple of
hits and a man left we go to the sixth
padres three giants one a two out number
that brings the tying run to the plate
with mauricio damon
fly ball right field over his myers
myers is there he makes the catch and
the padres win
both ends of a double header and they
sweep the giants and the padres have now
won seven in a row